The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Greg was
not here yesterday.
He was away.
And so this is work he's
largely done on his own again.
He's done a molecular
dynamics simulator.
So he's going to tell us
a little bit about that,
and then after that we'll
do course evaluations,
hand out some awards, have
some cake, and then after that
some pizza, and then
play same PlayStation 3s.
All yours.
GREG PINTILIE: OK, so
I'll talk about the make
general molecular
dynamics algorithm
and then parallelization
approaches.
So molecular dynamics is based
on a potential energy function,
which includes two terms, bonded
terms and non-bonded terms.
And bonded terms are split
up into three sub terms.
So don't confuse
bonded with-- actually,
don't think that
these are non-bonded.
These are actually all
sort of grouped as bonded.
I know it's a little
bit confusing,
but right now I'm dealing just
with the sort of bonded terms.
And what that means
is that it deals
with atoms that are connected
together covalently.
So for example, the bonds
term reflects some energy
due to a displacement
between two atoms, which
are certain distance apart.
There is an equilibrium distance
that they like to stay at,
and if they vary
from that distance
the potential increases as
a squared of that separation
distance.
The angles term
represents, basically,
the deviation from
an equilibrium
angle between three atoms.
So if you imagine these
three nodes as three atoms,
if this angle varies away
from a certain equilibrium
theta or angle, then
the potential energy
is also a quadratic
term, which tends
to bring the three atoms to have
a certain equilibrium angle.
And then, finally, the
dihedral and improper term
is probably one of the
more complicated ones.
The improper term basically
deals with four atoms.
So if you imagine this is
one, two, three, and four.
These three atoms, if you
put two planes through them,
the angle that those two
planes make to each other
is given a certain
equilibrium angle again.
And this should also
be a quadratic term,
but the energy also
varies quadratically
as that angle is deviated from.
An actual dihedral
is the rotation
along a bond between
the two central atoms.
And this energy term has
actually a cosine form.
So as you rotate it along
this bond, say for example,
the energy will
very sinusoidally.
And there will be a
restoring potential that
will tend to make
it either a line,
or sometimes it will
make the atom stagger.
So all of these parameters are
very sort of molecule and atom
dependent.
And all of these
parameters are available,
or have been built over many
years by different methods
like ab initio calculations
or experimental calculations.
But basically, if you plug those
parameters in, for example,
here k represents the
spring constant, right?
Because they're basically
just like spring constraints
more or less.
Or in this case,
it will tell you
how far up the potential,
like what this value will
be at the maximum, and will,
for example, in this case,
will specify how
many fluctuations you
have in the energy function.
And the other
parameters are usually
the theta, the equilibrium
theta, or the equilibrium,
or the equilibrium bond length.
So this is kind of
what you can expect
for it to look like as
molecules will tend to move.
The non bonded terms
include van-der-Waals terms
and electrostatic terms.
So van-der-Waals forces
occur between any two atoms,
and if they're far enough apart,
they will attract to each other
according to this formula.
And if they're too
close together,
so at equilibrium
distance between them
the energy is a minimum,
but as they get any closer
there will be a very strong
group repulsive force, which
is the r to the 12th term.
And as they get
further apart, there
is an attraction force, which
varies as r to the sixth.
And then the electrostatic
force is just
a simple Coulombic form.
So you basically take
two atoms that are,
say oppositely charged,
will attract each other.
If they're positively charged
they will repel each other.
And it's just a matter of
multiplying the charges,
and then dividing by
r to get the energy.
OK, so to do molecular
dynamics, basically,
you have to take derivatives
of all those formulas.
I just showed you.
And I didn't do that all myself.
It was pretty hard.
I just got some code from
some current existing
molecular dynamic simulators.
But basically, you
take the derivative.
And that basically equates
to the force, right?
The typical Newton
Newtonian model.
And that gives you the
force in every atom,
and then using that force
and integration scheme,
the leapfrog Verlet
integration scheme just
gives you the velocity at
the next half time step.
And then using that velocity
at the half time step,
the positions of
each atom is updated
based on the positions at
the previous time step,
and then some value.
So I will show you
a little bit of what
it looks like on a
simple molecule first.
So here's a sort
of simple molecule,
and it has just an
initial configuration
that is just sort of random.
And so one technique
that is done
is first the geometry
is minimized,
which means that you
just take small steps
in the direction of the gradient
until you reach the energy
minimum.
And if I do that,
I sort of reach
sort of the minimum
configuration
that this molecule
likes to be in.
And then, if I add some thermal
noise, which means that I just
set the initial
velocities of the atoms
to some random value
based on the temperature,
then the molecule starts
sort of jiggling around.
And the nice thing about the
Verlet integration scheme
is that it's
actually just right,
like the energy is
conserved in the system,
although it fluctuates
a little bit.
So a lot of integration
schemes the energy
tends to be either
decrease or increase,
so the system explodes.
But this integration
scheme is very stable.
One thing that you saw there
is, so I just talked briefly
about kinetic energy.
This is kind of how the
initial velocities are
set based on the Boltzmann
constant and the temperature.
And the other thing that
molecular dynamics usually do
is called Langevin dynamics.
And in this case, some
random velocity vector
is added to the normal velocity,
which just sort of simulates
collisions with other
molecules in the environment.
So this makes the simulation
look a bit more realistic.
So instead of the molecule
just sitting there in space,
this random sort of
factor adds some movement.
And there's also a
damping constant,
which sort of opposes the
velocity by some constant.
So if you didn't add any
more sort of randomness
into the system, the system
would just eventually go
to be completely still.
So there would be
no more movement,
because this is kind of like
a damping sort of factor.
And there are some properties
of this random vector that sort
of make some physical sense.
For example, it's independent
of previously picked
random vectors, and it also
depends on the temperature.
So that if you keep
adding this random factor
to the simulation,
the temperature
will always stay constant.
Another thing to consider
is that these molecules,
if you try to think
of them as they
are in a sort of typical
biological system,
is that they'll be
solvated in water.
So in that case
the Coulombic term
is not actually that simple.
You have to include some
sort of dielectric constant.
So for example, one
that is typically used
and is pretty simple is that the
constant is just the distance.
So that makes the electrostatic
energy dependent on one over r
squared rather than 1 over r.
So that means that the
electrostatic forces drop off
a lot faster as the atoms get
further and further apart.
So for example, so two molecules
that are oppositely charged,
if you just put them in
vacuum, they will eventually
come close together.
But if you add this term,
the electrostatic attraction
will be much weaker.
So it will simulate them
being solvated in water.
And they will come
together eventually
but probably a lot slower.
Another thing that
is typically--
so I'll talk a little bit
about the non-bonded forces
right now, which are, again,
the electrostatic forces
and the van-der-Waal's forces.
So generally, what
has to be done
is, if you consider
any single atom
like say this one
over here, well,
so first of all the
bonded forces basically
include just the atoms that are
connected to it, and that's it.
So it's usually the fastest
step in the computation.
But for non-bonded forces,
you have to consider basically
every other atom in the system.
And I didn't include
all of the atoms here,
but basically just
to give an idea,
they could be atoms that
are really far apart.
So generally,
what's done is there
is some cut off radius,
outside of which
those forces aren't considered.
And because the forces
drop off really fast,
sometimes that's considered
to be good enough
for a lot of simulations.
So that's a consideration
to take into account
when doing these simulations.
OK, so here's the basic
molecular dynamics algorithm.
So you specify how many
steps you want to run it to.
And each time step
is one femtosecond.
So very small.
So usually what happens is
you can find the atom pairs.
So that means all the
non-bonded interactions,
you have to make a list,
basically an n squared list.
If you have n atoms,
you can expect
to have about n
squared atom pairs.
But if you consider a cut
off, then what's usually done
is only atom pairs
within that cut off
are considered and
included into that list.
And that computation
is pretty expensive,
d it's sometimes only done only
every, say every ten steps.
And atoms don't
really move that much.
So it's usually pretty accurate.
And if you use a cut off of, say
15 angstroms, and then, well,
the forces have dropped to
almost zero by 12 angstroms,
then that's pretty accurate.
So this is usually
an optimization.
It optimizes the
simulation a little bit.
The next step is to
compute the bonded forces.
So that includes the
bonds, angles, dihedrals
and improper angles.
And then compute the
non-bonded forces,
so that iterates over
all the atom pairs.
And then the integration is
done to obtain the new atom
positions.
So here's, running
on the PlayStation,
this is kind of roughly how
this is just running on the PPU
alone.
So finding the atom pairs,
if I don't use a cut off,
I can just compute the
atom pairs list once,
and then never do it again.
So that's why I put here 0.
But otherwise, generally
takes a lot of time
to compute the atom
pairs, because it
involves getting the distances
between every two atoms.
And this is a pretty big
system, maybe about 1,000 atoms.
So that's why.
So these times are not really
representative of smaller
systems.
AUDIENCE: What is
BF [INAUDIBLE]?
GREG PINTILIE:
BF, so that's done
using the brute force approach.
So that means that you
check every two atoms.
And this is using a KD tree,
so that breaks space up.
So then checking the
neighboring atoms is n log n.
Or it's actually
a constant factor
after you've built the tree.
Building the tree is n log n.
So using that kind
of an algorithm,
you get much better improvement.
So this is a scaling of
increasing the system size
by two in the number of atoms.
So say going from
1,000 to 2,000 atoms.
The time too, using a
brute force approach,
increases exponentially.
Whereas, using a KD tree, it
actually just about doubles.
So that kind of shows that using
a better algorithm sometimes
for these things is
probably much better
than trying to parallelize it.
Doing the bonded forces,
say about 50 milliseconds,
and with cut off it's the same
time, because it doesn't really
affect the step.
But then computing
the non-bonded forces
is actually the
biggest chunk of time.
So that takes about 1.4
seconds for the system.
And then this is
considering a million pairs.
With a cut off there is
less pairs to consider,
but the time is still the
dominant time basically.
So generally, for molecular
dynamic simulations
this is the dominant
time factor.
And that's what people
really focus on,
trying to speed things up.
And then the integration
is really fast,
because it just loops
over the atoms once.
So there is basically three
different parallelization
approaches that I've come
across in the literature.
And one of them is referred
to as force decomposition.
So if you think of a
force operation being,
say a non-bonded force operation
where you consider two atoms,
and you compute the force
the two, van-der-Waals
and electrostatic forces,
one easy way to split this up
amongst, say six processors,
is to just give each processor,
say n divided by 6 of
these force operations.
So you have to send each
processor both atom positions,
and then some other properties
of the atoms, such as the mass
and-- actually not the mass,
but the charges and the minimum
radius.
And basically, once that
computation is done,
the processor just has to
either store or return the force
on both atom.
And it has to come back to
sort of like the main processor
where all the
forces are added up,
and then the
integration is done.
So what I just described is
sort of the approach I took.
And it's sort of
an easy approach
to sort of think of
if you couldn't store,
say every atom on
every processor.
Because you just have
to send each processor
a certain number of these
force computation units.
And the processor does then
and then returns the forces.
And then you can just add up
all the forces on every atom
and do that.
So basically here is the
algorithm how it works roughly.
And so basically,
first set up the SPUs,
send the control box
with, say the addresses
where a these force
operations will be stored.
The bonded forces are
computed on the PPU,
just for simplicity for now.
And then the computation
for the non-bonded forces,
basically, all the non-bonded
forces operations remaining
are considered.
And then they're
split up into blocks.
So each SPU sent
a block with, say
a number of force operations.
And in this case it was 200.
So the control block
is sent to the SPU,
the SPU is told to
start processing.
And then the PPU waits
for each SPU to finish.
And then once the
SPU is finished,
the forces are added to the
two atoms that are involved
in that force computation.
And then this loop is done
once all the SPUs are finished.
And then it goes,
in this repeats
until there is non-bonded
operations remaining.
So for example here,
just to illustrate this,
let's say these are all
the non-bonded operations I
have to do.
And I'm going to use two SPUs.
And each SPU can only store,
say three force operations.
So each SPU is sent by a block.
I mean that, say
these three operations
are sent to each SPU.
The SPU does them.
The next block is sent to the
next SPU at the same time,
and then that SPU also does it.
And this is iteration
0 for example.
And this is done until all
of the force computations
are done.
So here's a timing.
So you might imagine
that, as I said,
there is there is a
lot of communication
overhead over here.
So here's how this performs.
So on the PPU, the MD
simulation per time step,
runs in 310 milliseconds.
On one SPU, the time was
up to 630 milliseconds.
So there is a lot of
communication overhead here.
On two SPUs it goes
back down to 390.
And as the number of
SPUs is increased,
it gets lower and lower.
But it's not that much
better than really running it
sequentially.
And the reason is that the way
I implemented is pretty rough.
One of the limitations, I mean
one very obvious optimization
that should be done
is that SPU basically
waits for this whole
block to arrive,
and then starts computation.
But really what I
should have done
is once one force
computation arrives,
you can already do
that computation.
Instead of waiting for all
of them to be transferred
and then starting
to do the operation.
So that I think that
could've been a lot better.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GREG PINTILIE: No.
So right, so this is sort
of the simplest approach,
I mean sort of a simple
approach to implement
on this architecture.
And it sort of scales
well as the system grows.
So if you can't store
every item, for example,
in every SPU, this
doesn't really care.
The system can grow
as large as you want.
There's some other
approaches that are
done sort of in the literature.
I didn't implement
these, but another one
is called atomic decomposition.
So here, if you have,
say a number of atoms,
you send each one of
these atoms to one SPU.
And then that SPU is solely
responsible for computing
the forces on it,
and also integrating
to get the new positions.
And then all you
have to communicate
is the atomic positions.
But this is a little
bit more complicated,
because then every
SPU has to know
about all of the
force computations
that you want to do.
So for example, in this
case it's just a non-bonded,
but the SPU also
has to know about--
AUDIENCE: So that would
be like the same example
that we did in [INAUDIBLE].
GREG PINTILIE:
Yeah, it would be.
Yeah, the only problem
with that approach
is that if the system was
much larger than the SPU could
store, and you couldn't store
every single atom on the SPU,
then an operation might refer
to atoms that are not there.
So yeah, it would
be similar to that.
But it would get more
complicated in this case
as a system grew,
because you'd have
to keep track of where
each atom is and then
implement communication.
If you don't have
a certain atom,
to get to that atom
position and use it
in the force computation.
So yeah, this approach, OK,
I'll talk a little bit more
about this.
This is a--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] I mean
not SPU, but [INAUDIBLE].
GREG PINTILIE:
That's true, yeah.
So you only sort of give
a certain number of atoms
to every SPU, and then, yeah.
That's true.
And then you would have to sort
of store every single force
that that atom is
included in on the SPU.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GREG PINTILIE: Yeah, like when
this will become a problem is,
say the system was much larger
than you had local store.
Then say you had like
1/10 of the system on SPUs
and then 9/10 of the
system on the PPU.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GREG PINTILIE: Yeah, it
would be hard to think
of it scaling properly.
So a special case of
this atomic decomposition
is actually spatial
decomposition.
OK, I'm almost done.
So a special case of
spatial decomposition.
So what makes this
approach sort of not good,
and it sort of involves
a lot of communication,
is just this fact that some
of these force computations,
or force operations that
you have could include atoms
on different units.
So if you don't split up
these atoms sort of smartly,
then you could end up
having to communicate a lot
while computing these forces.
So spatial decomposition
tries to address this.
And basically, you store atoms
that are close to each other.
So say I had the system, and
I wanted to split this up
on six SPUs, then right,
I would give each SPU,
say a certain area of space.
But you could see right away
what the problem with this is
is that it's not load balanced.
So some SPUs could not
have too much work to do.
And there's still some
communication, because you
have to communicate
between neighboring SPUs,
say some certain cases.
But the communication
is still probably
a lot better than in
the previous case,
just for atomic decomposition.
So here's the state of the
art on parallelization MD.
And it's implemented
in this program called
NAMD, which stands for Not
Another Molecular Dynamics
simulator.
So initially, NAMD 1.0 used
solely a spatial decomposition.
And they try to address
this load balancing
by actually creating many
more patches than you
have processors.
And then you just sort of
split these patches up,
load balance them amongst
the different processors.
That didn't really work.
So NAMD 1 didn't
parallelize very well.
So what they added
later was they
added this idea
of patch objects,
and also compute objects.
So basically a patch
object puts a number
of patches on a
processor, but then you
can also create compute
patches, which include
all of these force operations.
And these force operations
are also equally distributed
amongst processors.
And then there's a
lot communication
between these two.
And it started off with sort
message oriented communication.
Then it moved to a dependency
oriented communication
so that each compute
object would sort
of signal which atoms it needs.
And it also sort
of optimized things
by doing communication and force
computation at the same time.
So it did that really well.
And actually it had really
good parallel performance.
So on this graph it shows
the number of processors
times the time per time step.
And as the number of
processors is increased,
I mean optimal
parallel performance
would be a straight horizontal
line, which is pretty
close to what they achieve.
And they also did it on
many thousands of processors
on Blue Gene.
But as you might expect,
the more processors
you add, the step time actually
still sort of levels off
at a certain time.
So I guess I'll skip the sort
of live demo I was going to do,
but I'll just show
one more thing.
So here is sort of the kind of
systems that I was looking at.
This is actually
a simulation that
was done on one of the
PPUs and then recorded
in positions file.
And there is five
different molecules here.
So generally, what happens
is first they're just
placed randomly.
Then they're an overlap
just very coarsely,
to make sure that
huge forces are not
entered into the system.
And I'll just color
each one differently.
So here's what happens
during the simulation.
And here, in this simulation,
actually, the positions
were recorded every
20 time steps.
So that's why it sort of
seems to go a lot faster.
If I did it on a
single molecule,
I actually done that first.
So here what a single
molecule of this looks like.
And this is a protein with eight
residues, which is pretty big.
And this is running in real
time on my computer right now.
So like on a small system like
this, it runs reasonably fast.
But as you add more and
more of these things,
the computations do
get pretty expensive.
So parallelization really helps.
Well, not in what I
implemented, but generally.
Generally, as you saw, NAMD
can do a pretty good job
at doing it.
Oh OK, I didn't minimize
the system well enough.
But yeah, that's about it.
AUDIENCE: Great. [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: So
basically, on the SPUs,
you managed to get them
synchronized properly, data in
and data out?
GREG PINTILIE: Yeah, exactly.
So that's kind of to
the extent that I went.
And that still took a long time.
So [INAUDIBLE].